[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el mundo
entero siguió las impactantes imágenes
que dejó la erupción de un volcán
submarino en el archipiélago de tonga
que afectó seriamente esta nación
insular en el pacifico las erupciones
sucedidas en este país provocaron una
serie de tsunamis que también impactaron
las costas de varios países entre ellas
las costas de perú a poco más de 10 mil
600 kilómetros de distancia
pero no emitió una alerta de tsunami
como sí lo hicieron sus vecinos ecuador
y chile que alertaron por anticipado a
los ciudadanos residentes en las costas
y por eso hubo tiempo suficiente para
resguardarlos y prestarles la asistencia
necesaria cosa contraria sucedió en perú
en donde dos personas murieron los
efectos del tsunami se verían poco
tiempo después al presentarse un derrame
de petróleo causado presuntamente por el
fuerte oleaje que afectó a un barco de
la petrolera española repsol mientras
descargaba crudo frente a las costas
peruanas el resultado cerca de 18 mil
kilómetros de zonas partes afectadas con
una amplia variedad de plantas y
animales pues que han vivido en los
últimos días todos los problemas y las
complicaciones que traen estos derrames
de crudo en el mar el gobierno declaró
la emergencia ambiental por espacio de
90 días y como era de esperarse ni el
gobierno ni la petrolera asumen
responsabilidades y tratan de buscar
culpables mientras que los pescadores y
por supuesto el medio ambiente son los
más afectados
recientemente la fiscalidad de perú dio
inicio a una investigación para
establecer los culpables y también
varios expertos de naciones unidas-
llegaron a la ciudad de lima para
evaluar cuál es la situación entonces
cuáles serán los efectos a mediano plazo
tras este derrame quién debe responder
el gobierno por no emitir una alerta
temprana ante la llegada de las
marejadas causadas por ese tsunami o la
petrolera repsol por no haber puesto en
marcha un protocolo que le permitiera
evitar que este tipo de derrames tuviera
lugar mientras descargaba el crudo y a
su vez hacía frente a las olas que traía
este tsunami que venía desde las costas
de tonga
en esa dicotomía es donde quedan
entonces los pescadores y los residentes
locales qué se puede hacer para mitigar
entonces el impacto ambiental que ya va
a dejar este daño ecológico
la controversia tras el derrame de crudo
en perú es nuestro tema de debate en
france 24 y para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a fabiola muñoz ella es
coordinadora de la coalición por una
producción sostenible y extremista y
experta en medioambiente ella se
encuentra en la ciudad de lima en perú
también allí en la capital peruana está
alicia kuroiwa ella es directora de
hábitats y especies amenazadas ustedes
también nuestros televidentes pueden
participar en este debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas los pueden
hacer todos estos a través de las redes
sociales ustedes ya lo saben no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram y en
twitter estamos como france24 bajo ese y
mi cuenta personal
santi logo les recuerdo la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas comienzo
entonces el programa preguntándole a
fabiola de lima sobre el verdadero
impacto para comprender la dimensión de
esta de este daño ambiental el verdadero
impacto que tiene este derrame de crudo
en las costas peruanas
bueno realmente el impacto es un impacto
enorme vamos a no solamente tenemos 21
playas afectadas de lo que se ha
identificado hasta ahora tenemos también
una gran cantidad de especies de fauna
silvestre tanto aves mamíferos como
peces moluscos afectados por esta
situación tenemos además una serie de
problemas de contaminación en diferentes
espacios la arena toda la zona de playa
y además de eso tenemos algunas familias
cientos de familias probablemente
afectadas entre aquellos que son
pescadores entre aquellos restaurantes y
toda su cadena de abastecimiento que son
los que vendían en este tiempo de verano
entonces realmente el impacto no es
solamente ambiental es social es
económico es realmente una catástrofe
desde el punto de vista ambiental con
impactos mucho más allá del ambiente
galicia quiero conocer su perspectiva en
torno a esto que estamos hablando como
punto de partida para el debate y es el
impacto que tiene esto ya lo dice
fabiola no es solamente ambiental
también es social es económico desde su
perspectiva cuál es entonces la
verdadera magnitud de este daño
ambiental de este desastre presentado en
las costas peruanas
al final no
principalmente porque no se están
haciendo los estudios no se están
haciendo los muestreos necesario para
saber hasta dónde está llegando la
información que se tiene de dónde hasta
dónde está llegando es por gente capaz
de hacer análisis espaciales con
imágenes satelitales pero todavía no hay
un dato oficial sabemos ya por ejemplo
que al menos tres áreas protegidas están
siendo afectadas y una de ellas
grandemente la zona aves trabanco de lo
que estaba el servicio de áreas
naturales protegidas de perú estima que
el 80 por ciento de esta era protegida
está siendo afectada y ahí tenemos
varias especies que están en peligro
algunas van a ser para estar extintas
localmente como por ejemplo el gato
marino y la chita además de más de mil
pescadores que no solamente representan
a mil personas son mil familias que se
quedan sin sustento diario no solamente
por ahora mientras está
ocurriendo o se está conteniendo esperar
hambre sino por lo menos son varios
meses o quizás años hasta que se logre
limpiar o remediar el impacto que nunca
es al 100% si alicia continuó con usted
y quiero que en conjunto con fabiola nos
describan a la audiencia france24 que
está fuera de las fronteras de perú y
que no conocemos
cómo es esta zona de playa al norte de
lima donde está ocurriendo este desastre
cómo es ese ecosistema qué tipo de
animales hay allí en qué tipo de hábitat
es del que estamos hablando porque son
según mis notas son 18 mil kilómetros
cuadrados de zonas protegidas que han
sido afectadas
y todas tienen una amplia amplia
variedad de plantas y de animales usted
ya mencionaba algunos de los riesgos en
los que se encuentran en términos de dar
esa foto del ecosistema que está siendo
afectada
sí bueno no sé de dónde salieron los 18
mil kilómetros cuadrados como decía las
cifras oficiales que son dadas por la
uefa todavía son muy bajas calculan más
o menos
700 700 kilómetros cuadrados de mar
afectado y unos 150 kilómetros
cuadrados de
tierra o de zona costera afectada no
sabemos que haya llegado la mancha del
petróleo hasta el norte de lima hasta
wilde huaura más o menos que son
alrededor de 100 kilómetros en la mancha
se ha extendido por lo menos 100
kilómetros en la línea costera y
teniendo tres áreas protegidas ya da una
idea de la importancia para la
biodiversidad que tiene esta área
afectada
nosotros tenemos la corriente de
humboldt y uno de los males el mar más
rico del mundo bueno en estas primeras
cinco millas es donde se daba el
afloramiento y además donde hay de sobra
hay hay un grupo de islas islotes y
donde son zonas de cría es también de
especies marinas no toda la fauna todos
los crustáceos que son que están en las
rocas ya murieron y no por esta
contestación que ustedes han visto en
las imágenes como esa rockería está
cubierto de esta mancha negra de
petróleo
fabiola y su complemento a esta pregunta
sobre el panorama de este ecosistema
alicia ya nos profundizaba un poco y
habla de la corriente ustedes están en
verano en este momento cómo se comporta
el mar en esta época del año allí en las
costas peruanas sabemos que la mancha se
está moviendo hacia el norte que tanto
puede avanzar puede cubrir la costa
peruana llegar a la costa ecuatoriana o
dispersarse a lo largo del pacífico que
se puede decir al respecto
fabiola
bueno creo que tenemos creo que tenemos
un problemita técnico con la conexión de
fabiola muñoz y en la ciudad de lima
entonces sigo comentando este tema con
alicia nuestra otra invitada también
allí en la capital peruana alicia le
preguntaba entonces a fabiola sobre el
movimiento de la corriente usted lo
mencionaba la corriente de humboldt
ustedes están en verano no sé si la
estación de pronto
signifique algo para el desplazamiento
que pueda tener esta mancha que se está
moviendo hacia el norte de las costas de
lima si lo que va a suceder en realidad
es que no sé si llegue mucho más allá
del norte porque luego de un tiempo el
petróleo se va degradando
y se va y se va a profundizar se
convierte algunos compuestos que se van
a evaporar que ya se están evaporando y
eso causa un daño a la salud humana ya
hay dos personas que han tenido que ser
evacuadas por este por haber inhalado
estos hidrocarburos
lo que se va a profundizar que son como
gotitas pequeñitas que se mencionan no
junto con el agua se va a profundizar yo
lo que vas a descubrir el fondo marino y
allí
no se ven una mancha de petróleo en la
superficie que soy yo qué causa como
buena impresión al público en general y
una vez que esto se profundice todos nos
vamos a olvidar eso es ese es el mayor
problema no quede claro
alicia parte de la controversia radica
en esa alerta de tsunami después de la
erupción volcánica en tonga a más de
10.000 kilómetros de las costas de perú
países vecinos ya lo mencionaba yo chile
y ecuador si emitieron una alerta para
toda la costa de sus respectivos países
y vimos las marejadas que llegaron al
norte de chile- principalmente la ciudad
de iquique que resultó
afectada a su costa por por estas olas
de gran tamaño pero no hizo ningún tipo
de alerta pero no tiene alerta de
tsunami para este tipo de casos que
falló allí que sabe usted de estos
procedimientos
nosotros la marina de guerra es la que
da la alerta de tsumani a través de la
dirección de hidrografía hidrografía y
navegación dijo que no había una alerta
de tsunami pero en realidad con el
derrame no es puede o no puede ser el
causante el maremoto no
el tsunami del derrame sin embargo el
problema está en que la empresa teniendo
un plan de
emergencia y de contingencia porque días
después se dio a conocer que si también
de contingencia no lo puso no lo
implementó no desde el primer minuto que
ese supo que había un derrame la empresa
dijo repsol dijo al inicio que solamente
fueron 27 galones de combustible que se
derramaron en un área afectado área de
2.5 metros cuadrados no dice que se
dieron cuenta al día siguiente cuando ya
había un mancha el petróleo cubriendo
playas y los pescadores dieron cuenta de
eso las autoridades peruanas entonces
para nosotros
ilegalmente el error está en no haber
implementado el plan de contingencia
como se debía hasta el momento no hay
indicios ni pruebas que repsol este por
ejemplo limpiando el petróleo que está
en el mar no las instituciones peruanas
como el servicio nacional de áreas
protegidas
no sé cómo han conseguido por ejemplo
dos skimmers y están tratando de
levantar el petróleo que está en las
áreas protegidas pero no es suficiente
no eso no es suficiente y en las playas
cuando vemos cómo están limpiando
heladas es como no sé si ustedes también
le llaman igual persona recoge con
recogedores están sin levantando el
petróleo no entonces dónde está el plan
de contingencia una transnacional que no
obtenga la tecnología de punta para
limpiar estos derrames es ese lauritto
no es criminal que siempre debe existir
pensaría uno en estas grandes
corporaciones un plan de acción un plan
de crisis de manejo de crisis de cómo
solucionar estos casos que en caso una
petrolera pues deben ser unos escenarios
factibles y también cómo reaccionar para
informar a la comunidad ya las
autoridades además a esto hay que sumar
un un punto importante y eso es parte de
la investigación es que efectivamente el
derrame sea consecuencia de las
marejadas causadas por ese tsunami
procedente de tonga o si simplemente es
una coincidencia que el derrame
estuviera ya en curso cuando esas olas
comenzaron a llegar a las costas
peruanas si los tiempos son los mismos y
los correctos pero como la empresa no ha
alertado en su momento a las autoridades
peruanas y como usted nos decía alicia
alberto cuando ya había manchas de
petróleo de crudo en las costas y fueron
los pescadores los que alertaron no la
empresa ahí es donde empieza a armarse
el rompecabezas con unas falencias y con
unos puntos que no son muy claros y que
será la investigación la que dé cuenta
de eso en retomamos la conexión con
fabiola muñoz en la ciudad de lima para
continuar debatiendo sobre este tema
fabiola estábamos hablando sobre el
sistema de alerta que tiene perú sobre
estos tsunamis chile y ecuador sí
alertaron a sus pobladores costeros
sobre estas marejadas que se van a
presentar es deficiente este sistema en
perú siendo un país con alta sismicidad
que puede tener alertas de tsunamis es
algo que a lo que ustedes están
expuestos que fallo en este sistema de
alerta
bueno en realidad la marina de guerra
del perú que maneja todo el sistema de
información sobre lo que ocurre en el
mar siempre se ha caracterizado porque
tiene un sistema
con información con alerta que es
bastante profesional sin embargo en este
caso en particular la evaluación que
ellos hicieron y entiendo que la vaina
también está haciendo su propia
investigación interna la evaluación que
ellos diciendo en el terminal no habían
condiciones para dar la alerta resulta
ahora un oleaje anómalo una situación de
una marejada
una crecida del mar un movimiento de
este tipo previamente puede ocasionar
una
acción que no estaba prevista para la
empresa y yo por eso se paró en realidad
en dos momentos esta situación uno es el
momento en el que se produce o las
circunstancias que rodean el derrame y
efectivamente ahí hay que investigar
cuál fue realmente la son si fue el
oleaje anómalo como deduce la empresa si
fue un error humano o si no se pudo
prever qué fue lo que pasó pero luego de
que se produce el derrame ya la
discusión de es otra porque nuestro
sistema no cierto independientemente que
la marina haya o no haya dado su
información en nuestro sistema y que
contamina paga'
y entonces una vez producción derrame
repsol era responsable de haber hecho
todo lo que está a su alcance para
contener el derrame para limpiarlo y
para remediar desgraciadamente su
actuación fue perdida no dimensionaron
el impacto y aunque no tiene que
investigar si realmente la información
de la marina era inexacta o no
esto es algo que se ha dejado crecer
demasiado y en ese sentido creo que sí
es muy importante reconocer que por
supuesto pueden haber oportunidades de
mejora en los sistemas de alerta de
tsunamis eso es algo en lo que el perú
ha venido trabajando hace tiempo ya pero
eso tiene que separarse de lo que
estamos viviendo con respecto a una vez
que se produjo el derrame
ese tipo de respuesta que se espera por
parte de las empresas que ha sido el
punto de crítica ya lo dicen ustedes por
parte de la sociedad peruana el mismo
gobierno y también de la comunidad
internacional la respuesta que ha dado
la petrolera española cuál es la
respuesta entonces que debe haber dado
haber desplegado
barcos equipos gente personal en cómo es
la respuesta habitual en este tipo de
daños ambientales y en este tipo de
derrames de petróleo en el mar
en los temas ambientales el tiempo
cuenta muchísimo no es lo mismo el
impacto que se va a generar durante las
primeras horas donde se puede contener
en el mar por supuesto hay un impacto
pero el impacto no es tan grande como
sigue esto llega hacia la costa afecta a
la fauna entra a la rockería social
llegó al área protegida por supuesto
porque estaba muy cerca en el mar esto
es un área como islotes y puntas
guaneras pero también llegó a la otra
área no está más
digamos al norte entonces
y la respuesta tiene que ser con gran
sentido de urgencia y transparentando la
información la las empresas muchas veces
tienen temor de reportar porque dicen sí
reportó gran echar la culpa me dan a ser
responsable y esto todavía hay que
investigarlo pero lo cierto es que los
temas ambientales el costo de no actuar
oportunamente no estamos mirando esto es
una desgracia ambiental aquí la empresa
dice yo cumplí con la ley de la
capitanía de puertos no es cierto la
reporte a la institución oficial que es
en este caso al cine al mismo efe pero
eso es lo que la ley le pide es lo
mínimo que tiene que hacer pero ante una
situación de este tipo el reporte de la
versión mayor informar a la ciudadanía
informar a las autoridades buscar si
había habido un derrame pues ampliar el
área de búsqueda ellos dicen buscamos en
el área contigua no nos percatamos de
que había un derrame
la empresa sabe cuando tenía el petróleo
y saben cuánto llegó a descargar y hay
una diferencia de mil barriles entonces
eso tendría que alertar que algo había
estaba faltando y hacer esto
transparente y público lo más rápido
posible para poder controlar esto antes
de que llegue a la constante de que
llegue a la orilla alicia ya le voy a
dar la palabra voy a continuar con fallo
la para hacer un poco aquí de balance en
la participación
fabiola usted habla de transparencia y
estamos en américa latina en donde uno
de los graves problemas es la corrupción
pero no es ajeno a ese escenario y tipo
de situaciones como éstas tienden a
politizarse de hacer presas de la
corrupción
temen ustedes que este caso esta
investigación y este desastre ambiental
caiga en las manos de personas que no
son adecuadas para su manejo y se
politice entra a ser parte de estos
círculos de corrupción y simplemente se
lavan las manos y nadie responda y no
pase nada y el daño ambiental que
derecho
hay tres cosas que creo que es
importantísimo tener en cuenta en
función de esta pregunta la primera es
que una de las mejores formas de luchar
contra la corrupción es la transparencia
por eso mi recomendación a la empresa al
estado a todos los actores que están
involucrados es ser lo más transparente
posible mantener a la opinión pública
informada a la transparentar lo que se
está haciendo día a día cuánto está
costando cuánto se está invirtiendo de
todas las partes lo segundo es que no
puede haber un aprovechamiento político
de una situación como ésta en este
momento lo que necesitamos es convocar a
los actores
bueno hemos perdido nuevamente la
conexión con fabiola pasó a hacerle la
pregunta entonces alicia ya hemos
analizado un poco el papel que ha tenido
repsol de esta petrolera española pero
que hay que decir del gobierno peruano
como ha sido la respuesta para hacer
frente a esta situación a esta crisis
cuál es su opinión al respecto alicia
sí en general creo que la respuesta el
estado peruana sea muy pobre en realidad
el estado pero no debe exigir a la
empresa que actúe hasta el momento no
vemos esa acción de contener el petróleo
y sigue contaminando otras playas sigue
los animales siguen contaminando se y
más pescadores vamos a sufrir estos
impactos tienen que exigirle en estado
penal no tiene que exigir a la empresa
la empresa que implemente su plan de
contingencia ahora ha dado unos tiempos
no el ministerio ambiente junto con la
uefa a unos tiempos se supone que hoy
día debes de estar terminando de limpiar
los las playas contaminadas ni siquiera
tienen mapeadas creo todas las playas
que están contaminadas entonces cómo van
a limpiarlas y eso por un lado por otro
lado en el caso de la investigación ya
de la fiscalía nosotros tenemos mucha
confianza en la labor que hace la fema
la fiscalía especializada en materia
ambiental pero lo que se necesita lo que
no se quería necesita mucho es el apoyo
de personas y profesionales que conozcan
que puedan por ejemplo hacer una
valoración del impacto que tiene este
derrame en todo nivel no solamente en el
ambiental no sino como decía fabiola
en los pescadores sociales y
económicamente
galicia del mar hacia adelante no
solamente es los pescadores no sino toda
una maquinaria que está atrás con
turismo y toda la cadena de valor de ese
pescado que se está dejando de pescar
los restaurantes la gente que lleva a la
playa no va a tener un descanso hay un
montón de actividades que han sido 80
hablar usted habla en galicia que tiene
confianza en la fiscalía que va a
investigar este tema ya lo está
investigando de hecho ya ha comenzado
las pesquisas pertinentes y le repito la
pregunta que le estaba haciendo a
fabiola teme usted que esto se politice
que esto caiga en manos que no son y que
entre la corrupción que es algo muy
habitual en américa latina
y por supuesto que hoy vemos que en
nuestro país hay muchos procesos que
están
oficializados y que toman años de años
en terminarse en concluirse y al final
las sentencias pueden ser no de acuerdo
al impacto el daño causado sino a quien
sabe que no son muy pocas o se perdonan
multas que deben de pagar las multas son
muy bajas tanto que a veces es más
barato para una empresa pagar la multa
que solucionar el problema no claro
fabiola en ese sentido entonces qué
sanciones puede haber en contra de la
compañía petrolera
retirarle la licencia de explotación en
perú simplemente una millonaria multa
que pagara fácilmente podrá retomar su
actividad como debe ser este
procedimiento desde su opinión
bueno hay un marco jurídico que es el
que regula lo que se puede y no se puede
hacer lo primero es que estamos en el
estado de derecho y ese tiene que ser un
mensaje muy importante para todos los
muertos e inversionistas sobre todo que
hay que respetar el orden jurídico pero
por supuesto una acción de este tipo
como decía alicia tiene que estar
adecuadamente cuantificada no solamente
poli tema de la multa sino porque hay
que hacer que la empresa también pague
la indemnización eso es parte de la
responsabilidad que puede tener y en esa
inversión cuando se evalúe con cierto la
situación habrá que considerar un montón
de acápites de diferentes tipos no
solamente el daño a la fauna silvestre
no solamente la pérdida de amor que
tenemos económicamente de los
restaurantes y como decía listas no es
solamente el pescador que no puede
pescar es toda una cadena y está detrás
entonces hay que cuantificar esto las
especies que más perdidos hay una salida
de nutrias personas y como ya decía
vamos a tener una extinción local
de una especie que era muy particular
tan importante es la biodiversidad de
esta área que tenemos zonas declaradas
áreas naturales protegidas
entonces como decía la primera forma de
luchar contra la corrupción es la
transparencia la segunda
la información la ciudadanía tiene que
tener información y lo tercero y esto es
un llamado y concuerdo con lo que dice
alicia necesitamos un liderazgo del
estado peruano que convoque los actores
que organicen la respuesta esta empresa
por más que hagan estos mismos solistas
tampoco va a poder o sea por supuesto
que tiene que poner los recursos y
hacerse responsable pero hay que actuar
en conjunto la marina áreas naturales
protegidas el servicio nacional forestal
e zona silvestre los ministerios el
ministerio del ambiente todos los
actores en su conjunto y eso requiere un
liderazgo
convocante y comprometido del estado
peruano
fabiola hace pocos días llegó a la
ciudad de lima una delegación de
naciones unidas para investigar y
evaluar estos hechos exactamente qué
hacen este tipo de comisiones que llegan
de estos organismos internacionales que
tanto puede ayudar en este caso pensaría
yo en la investigación o cuál puede ser
su aporte
bueno yo creo que hay tres cosas que
pueden hacer por nosotros lo primero
efectivamente es conducir una
investigación muy objetiva muy
transparente muy clara para dejar bien
puesto los puntos sobre las íes como
decimos nosotros no sea que no haya una
manipulación de la información lo
segundo es que efectivamente
hay como decía alicia especialistas que
se necesitan y creo que naciones unidas
podría proveerle al perú no solamente de
recursos de la cooperación que podrían
hacerse también para la realización sino
de especialistas que junto con los
especialistas peruanos ayuden en el
trabajo de cuantificación pero también
de remediación o sea que hay un trabajo
todavía que hay que hacer y lo tercero
es mantener este tema
prendido y necesitamos que esto se siga
y que no exista impunidad para nadie
porque aquí también tenemos una
oportunidad de aprender como sociedad
prefiero que el anuncio haya venido en
un rol muy importante para nosotros
fabiola usted se adelantó un poco la
pregunta que les iba a hacer a las dos
para el cierre del programa comienzo
entonces por la línea para para alternar
un poco y es dejar al futuro y sé que es
muy temprano para decirlo porque las
investigaciones están en marcha y sólo
el tiempo nos mostrará qué fue lo que
sucedió exactamente en este en esta
crisis medioambiental pero qué
elecciones puede dejar esto para los
peruanos para las empresas y para los
ciudadanos que muchas veces no son muy
conscientes del entorno del hábitat y el
ecosistema en donde están disfrutando de
sus playas o disfrutando de su comida a
la orilla del mar y no son conscientes
de la importancia que tiene el entorno
en cuanto a la vida salvaje que hay allí
y bueno esperemos que una de las
principales lecciones que nos está dando
esta catástrofe es saber que el ambiente
importa que necesitamos un ministerio
del ambiente realmente fortalecido que
pueda batallar estos estados estos
problemas y que pueda hacerle frente a
sectores como yo no canguro que son tan
poderosos en nuestro país ya vimos que
por ejemplo el sector hidrocarburos paro
la creación de un área protegida en el
norte del país no entonces sí eso creo
creo que dice ser principal mensaje la
principal lección que debemos de recoger
de esta desgracia que si en el ambiente
importa no solamente por los animalitos
importa por todos nosotros
de alguna u otra manera nuestras vidas
dependen de un ambiente que sea
saludable
y que no nos podemos maltratar lo de
esta manera clara y fabiola su
conclusión sus impresiones y lo que se
puede decir deja como lección este tipo
de hechos medioambientales este daño
ecológico que sufre pero en este momento
concuerdo con lo expresado por alicia en
el sentido de que el ambiente importa
que también tenemos que tener un sistema
fortalecido una institucionalidad
ambiental fortalecida que sea capaz no
solamente de hacer frente a los otros
sectores de igual a igual sino de
convocar y articular otra lección
aprendida creo que es que tenemos que
pensar que esto nos puede pasar muchas
veces las empresas y el estado mismo no
piensa que no te va a pasar un accidente
no te va a pasar una catástrofe no te va
a pasar aquí por lo tanto relajas los
procedimientos de entrenamiento de
capacitación no tienes todos los equipos
que deberían tener para atender el
incendio el sismo el derrame de petróleo
entonces creo que hay que tener un
enfoque mucho más activo sobre el tema
de prevención y lo último es hemos visto
la respuesta de la ciudadanía la
sensibilidad que tienen los temas
ambientales creo que este es el momento
en el cual el perú tiene que el poder
decir que si nos importan desde el
estado el tema ambiental y sería una
buena forma reconocer el área nacional
protegida del norte del perú mar capital
de brawn que es un área extraordinaria y
donde deberíamos tener también un valor
de reconocer la biodiversidad de nuestro
mar y así necesitamos además ser capaces
todos los ciudadanos y ciudadanas de
entender lo frágil y vulnerable que es
no solo el mar sino nosotros mismos la
biodiversidad entonces el cambio
climático
requiere de un esfuerzo colectivo y
colaborativo pero tiene una agenda
climática importante tiempo nos debería
dar la oportunidad de reflexionar sobre
ese aspecto pues son múltiples las
lecciones que le dejan no solamente a
perú sino también a la región de américa
la tiene por qué no decirlo al mundo
entero con este desastre ecológico que
está viviendo
este país suramericano en sus costas con
este derrame de petróleo a causa de
posiblemente por estas marejadas son
provocadas por el tsunami que dejó la
explosión de la erupción mejor de un
volcán en tonga en oceanía alicia y a
fabiola les agradezco mucho por
conectarse con nosotros por explicarnos
el panorama de lo que está sucediendo
allí y analizar para la audiencia de
france 24 este tema que sin duda alguna
vamos a seguir tratando por las próximas
semanas porque la investigación apenas
está comenzando ustedes muchas gracias
por la sintonía y los invito para que
sigan dejando todos sus comentarios en
las redes sociales del canal y sigan
disfrutando la programación de france 24
[Música]